on va poursuivre sur ce sujet avec
Héloïse zeldom elle était associée de
recherche à l'Institut de l'énergie
Étretat bonsoir Monsieur Madame eldom
donc on avait l'impression que cette
entente qui était en vigueur entre le
Québec et l'Ontario entre Hydro-Québec
et l'Ontario elle était bénéfique pour
les deux provinces quelles étaient les
avantages de cette entente là en effet
cette entente là visait à exploiter la
complémentarité de la du profil de
consommation d'électricité entre le
Québec et l'Ontario c'est à dire qu'en
Ontario le pic de demande a lieu plutôt
en été et donc ils ont un peu plus
d'énergie disponible en hiver tandis que
au Québec notre Pic a lieu en hiver donc
on a plus de disponibilités en été donc
on échangeait selon les saisons cette
énergie là bon évidemment Marie-Claude
le mentionnait François Legault aurait
bien aimé que dogfood ait plus d'appétit
pour l'hydroélectricité du Québec
pourquoi l'Ontario décide à se pointer
de ne pas renouveler l'entente qu'est-ce
qui a changé depuis 2015 honnêtement
c'est une très bonne question pourquoi
parce que c'est une c'est décision qui
est assez surprenante en tout cas du
point de vue de la de l'énergie pourquoi
parce que selon la planification
actuelle de la du système de la Syrie
donc l'organisme qui s'occupe de la
planification en Ontario il y a un
manque d'énergie identifié depuis des
2025 2026 causé principalement par les
centrales nucléaires qui sont à peu près
en même temps en rénovation
ce manque à gagnant en termes
d'électricité suppose
de la nouvelle production et dans ce
moment c'est beaucoup le gaz naturel qui
gagne c'est beaucoup le gaz naturel qui
met de l'avant or mettre plus de gaz
naturel et complètement en décalage avec
les objectifs de décarbonation du Canada
de la province volontario qui n'est pas
encore engagée pour la carbone
neutralité mais tout de même qui a des
objectifs de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre et on se pose la question parce
qu'on parle souvent à cette émission du
fait que le gaz naturel coûte de plus en
plus cher il y a une montée des prix au
cours des derniers mois et les ont rien
fait déjà assez cher pour leur facture
d'électricité quel impact cette décision
là pour avoir sur la facture d'énergie
des Ontariens on peut supposer qu'il
risque d'avoir une augmentation du coût
parce que ce produire le gaz naturel qui
a été historiquement peu cher devient de
plus en plus cher comme vous l'avez
mentionné donc on peut supposer un
impact en terme d'augmentation sur les
coûts après comme la mentionner votre
collègue ce contrat ne signifie pas que
l'Ontario et le Québec ne vont plus
s'acheter de l'énergie entre eux donc ça
reste des opportunités je sais que
l'Ontario a signifié le fait que ils
veulent faire des appels à projets des
appels d'offres pour la pour remplir ce
besoin d'électricité il est probable que
Hydro-Québec puisse bien se positionner
là dessus toutefois peut-être que c'est
pas la priorité d'être au Québec étant
donné les autres contrats avec New York
et ma sasuchette donc c'est quand même
un risque d'avoir de ne pas renouveler
une entente qui nous assure que cette
électricité là va être disponible et du
point de vue d'Hydro-Québec jusqu'à un
certain point c'est pas c'est pas énorme
le fait de perdre cette entente non
c'est pas énorme quand on compare
justement au contrat avec New York il
massachuchette par exemple New York
c'est à peu près 10 terawatters la
mémoire de grandeur donc c'est c'est des
contrats pas mal mais simplement cinq
fois plus gros en termes d'énergie en
termes de rentabilité aussi donc comme
c'est des prix qui sont plus actuels qui
sont négociées dans les contrats donc
c'est probablement aussi des prix
d'exportation plus élevés donc pour
Hydro-Québec non ce n'est pas une grosse
perte du côté de l'Ontario vous avez
évoqué le nucléaire tout à l'heure
l'Ontario Parrot generation va prolonger
la durée de vie de la centrale Pickering
dont vous parliez le nucléaire on le
voyait c'est quand même une part assez
importante à peu près la moitié de
l'énergie en Ontario est-ce que ça va
être suffisant pour compenser si vous
voulez l'abandon de ces 2,3 terrawatts
en fait Pickering c'est pas encore sûr
que ça va être prolongé c'est la demande
a été faite mais ce n'est que la
Commission de l'énergie nucléaire du
Canada qui peut prendre la décision
là-dessus c'est sûr que si cette
centrale continue d'être ouverte ben là
on vient réduire le problème de
plusieurs ordres de grandeur mais reste
que pour donner un ordre de grandeur sur
l'horizon 2040 2042 on prévoit entre 12
terrasser voire 80t d'énergie manquantes
en Ontario une centrale nucléaire ne
fait pas 80 terroirs d'Europe c'est le
gaz naturel alors sur lequel on mise à
long terme du côté de l'Ontario pour le
moment en tout cas comme moyen terme
c'est le gaz naturel qu'on voit mais
encore une fois c'est quelque chose de
très questionnable étant donné les
objectifs de décarbonation qu'on a
sachant que une nouvelle centrale à une
durée de vie d'à peu près 40 ans donc
ouvrez une centrale nucléaire de gaz
naturel dans les deux trois prochaines
années c'est se bloquer avec cette actif
là pendant 40 ans donc on se pose la
question est-ce que cette décision là
bon elle est clairement pas prise du
point de vue environnemental d'abord
elle ne semble pas nécessairement être
justifié dès maintenant à tout le moins
du point de vue économique alors est-ce
que c'est une décision qui est politique
on peut se poser la question et les
indices tendent vers cette oui après ce
n'est pas un phénomène qu'on observe
seulement avec l'Ontario on remarque
dans beaucoup d'endroits il y a vraiment
une réticence de d'acheter d'échanger
l'électricité ce qui est un peu
surprenant quand on connaît le marché du
gaz naturel du pétrole qui circulent
énormément donc oui c'est une tendance
qu'on observe où on veut produire et
consommer chez soi peut-être que c'est
lié aux emplois postentiels que ça peut
générer
il y a aussi le côté d'infrastructures
parce que c'est vrai si on commence à
échanger plus d'énergie ça suppose de
mettre en place plus d'infrastructures
pour la transporter et la distribuer
donc avec les réticences au niveau de la
population qui ne veut pas c'est
nécessairement ces infrastructures là
donc ça peut être ce qui a posé dans la
balance pour cette décision bon chose
certaine décision qu'il y en a fait
sourciller plusieurs aujourd'hui et
Loïse et donne merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir ça me fait plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]